Traduttore: Noemi Deflorian
Revisore: Federico Sangati
A quanti di voi si è già impallato
il computer almeno una volta nella vita?
Quindi se vi è già successo sapete
che di solito capita
perché abbiamo troppi programmi aperti,
forse troppe finestre aperte;
stiamo facendo il cosiddetto multitasking.
Se vi è già successo sapete che a volte,
il modo migliore per farlo rifunzionare
è schiacciare il tasto reset,
oppure staccare la spina;
e questo è quello che succede
con il cervello elettronico,
ma non è molto diverso da quello
che succede con il cervello umano.
Provate a pensare a quanti minuti,
quante ore della nostra giornata
passiamo sempre connessi.
Il cellulare ormai è il primo oggetto
che prendiamo in mano la mattina,
e l'ultimo che abbandoniamo la sera;
ormai è diventato normale camminare
con il cellulare in mano.
Quello di cui forse non siamo consapevoli
è quante notizie, quante informazioni,
quante fonti di stress, quante emozioni
proviamo durante la giornata,
questo senza prenderci un attimo
per staccare la spina.
E allora può capitare che
anche noi andiamo in tilt.
In realtà è così semplice prendersi
un attimo per respirare, o no?
Se andiamo in tilt, cosa che probabilmente
ci è già successa, forse ci siamo chiesti:
“ma non è che c'è un tasto reset
anche per la testa?”
Io l’ho sperato diverse volte,
e l'ho trovato.
La buona notizia è che il tasto reset c'è,
ed è una pratica:
la pratica della meditazione.
In effetti è semplice
perché probabilmente non serve andare
per un mese sulle montagne dell'Himalaya,
per quanto bello possa essere,
per imparare a respirare.
A volte bastano cinque minuti,
per rimanere seduti in silenzio
ad ascoltare il suono del silenzio;
ed è quello che faremo adesso:
ci prenderemo cinque minuti per liberare
la nostra mente, per far spazio
per tutte le idee del TEDx che ci attendono
nella giornata di oggi;
e se c'è qualcuno tra di voi
che non ha mai fatto meditazione,
può darsi che in questo momento
provi una sensazione di irritazione.
Nel coaching lo chiamiamo “perturbazione”
ed è un ottimo segnale, perché vuol dire
che stiamo abbandonando la zona
di comfort, per imparare una cosa nuova.
Quindi vi chiedo adesso gentilmente
di trovare una posizione comoda,
[Musica]
Se avete le gambe accavallate
appoggiate entrambi i piedi per terra,
se siete seduti sugli sgabelli
potete lasciare i piedi sul poggiapiedi,
oppure appoggiare almeno un piede
sulla terra, per sentire il contatto;
vogliamo aprire il petto,
raddrizzare la schiena,
quindi gentilmente portate con me
le spalle innanzitutto in avanti,
ruotatele in alto e poi indietro;
quindi tenete la schiena dritta
senza irrigidirla; i palmi delle mani
sono rivolti verso il basso sulle cosce,
e chi di voi non vuole chiudere
completamente gli occhi li può tenere
semi aperti fissando un punto
senza focalizzarlo, in basso davanti a sé,
e chi invece come me vuole chiudere gli
occhi, lo faccia adesso.
[Musica]
Fate apparire un lieve sorriso
sulle vostre labbra;
e comincia ad osservare
il tuo respiro mentre entra ed esce
dal tuo corpo.
Osserva il tuo petto
mentre si alza e si abbassa,
fai del tuo meglio per portare
la tua attenzione al respiro;
[Musica]
e ora vai a notare, dove si trova la tua
mente in questo momento?
Forse ti ha portato al passato,
a cose che hai vissuto?
Forse ti ha portato al futuro,
a cose che ti aspettano?
Se è così, non giudicare
la tua mente,
semplicemente con gentilezza riportala
al tuo respiro.
[Musica]
E dove si trova la tua mente
in questo momento?
È qui nel presente, oppure no?
Se non si trova qui non giudicarla,
con gentilezza riportala al tuo respiro.
[Musica]
Ed ora ti chiedo per un attimo
di riflettere sul concetto
del non-giudizio; chiediti se sei una
persona che solitamente giudica le parole,
le idee, le emozioni;
le tue oppure quelle degli altri.
Se è così, prova a vedere
se per la giornata di oggi vuoi portare
un atteggiamento di apertura
e di curiosità;
[Musica]
e quando hai preso
la tua decisione, comincia a visualizzare
le persone che sono sedute di fianco a te,
davanti a te, dietro di te, le persone
che sono sedute in alto, oppure le persone
che sono sedute in basso,
le persone che ci stanno seguendo da casa;
e fai un sorriso anche a loro, prenditi un
attimo per augurare loro
buon giorno.
E mentre ci avviciniamo
alla fine della nostra pratica,
ricordati del posto nel quale ti trovi,
comincia a muovere leggermente
le dita delle mani e dei piedi,
e lentamente con gentilezza
apri gli occhi.
Grazie.
[Applausi]
Io vi ringrazio tantissimo,
perché questa mattina avete fatto
il primo passo oltre il convenzionale;
per alcune persone forse è stata
la prima esperienza di meditazione,
e quello che vi chiedo di fare adesso
è il secondo passo oltre al convenzionale.
Sì, perché tra un pò comincerò ad usare
degli aggettivi dedicati al femminile,
perché questo è quello che faccio
nei miei podcast di meditazione,
e perché la convenzione dice
che dobbiamo sempre
tutti sentirci inclusi,
non importa a quale genere sessuale
apparteniamo.
E allora perché non ribaltare
questa convenzione, e chiedere
a tutte di sentirsi incluse, non importa
a quale genere sessuale apparteniamo.
[Applausi]
Vi chiedo ora di trovare
una posizione comoda, di appoggiare
entrambi i piedi sul terreno,
ruotiamo insieme le spalle,
per trovare una posizione eretta
in avanti, in alto e indietro,
apriamo il petto senza irrigidirci,
poggiamo i palmi delle mani sulle cosce,
e chi vuole tenere gli occhi semichiusi
lo può fare, chi invece vuole chiudere
gli occhi insieme a me, lo faccia adesso.
[Musica]
Cominciano con tre respiri profondi,
inspireremo insieme, e quando espirerai,
immagina di avere uno specchio davanti
alla tua bocca che vuoi appannare,
quindi possiamo fare anche un pò
di rumore, inspira ed espira,
di nuovo inspira ed espira;
l'ultima volta:
inspira ed espira, benissimo;
ed ora con ogni espirazione immagina
di rilassare una parte in più
del tuo corpo; rilassa la fronte,
le tempie, rilassa gli occhi, le guance,
rilassa la lingua, rilassa la mandibola;
[Musica]
ed ora chiediti per un attimo come ti
senti; ti senti stanca?
Forse piena d'energia? Ti senti scettica?
Qualunque sia il modo
nel quale ti senti adesso,
non c'è giusto o sbagliato,
è semplicemente così com'è.
[Musica]
Ed ora ti chiedo di pensare ad una cosa
che ti ha colpito oggi;
può essere un'idea, una frase,
forse una pratica;
formula ora un'intenzione
nella tua mente, prendendo una promessa
con te stessa;
[Musica]
pensate adesso
ad un momento preciso nel tempo,
un giorno e un orario nel quale
vuoi iniziare con questa nuova pratica,
ad integrarla nella tua vita.
[Musica]
E quando hai deciso qual è
la tua promessa nei tuoi confronti,
ti chiedo ora di portare entrambe le mani
una sopra l'altra, e di appoggiarle
sul tuo cuore; e comincia a respirare
in questa parte del tuo corpo.
Senti il battito del suo cuore che batte
senza che debba fare nulla
di particolare perché accada;
e ora ti chiedo di portare nel tuo cuore
il sentimento della gratitudine,
e con ogni inspirazione, inspira
ancora più gratitudine nel tuo cuore.
E se ti può aiutare,
puoi ripetere silenziosamente dentro di te
per tre volte, una dietro l'altra,
la parola “grazie”.
[Musica]
E quando ti senti piena
di gratitudine, comincia ed estenderla
alle persone che sono sedute di fianco
a te, davanti a te, dietro di te,
estendila alle persone che sono sedute in
alto, e a quelle che sono sedute in basso,
alle persone che ci stanno seguendo
da casa;
[Musica]
e nota per un attimo
come ti senti.
Ed ora puoi riportare le due mani sulle
tue cosce, e mentre ci avviciniamo
alla fine della nostra pratica,
ricordati del posto nel quale ti trovi,
comincia a sentire i rumori attorno a te,
muovi leggermente le dita delle mani
e dei piedi, e quando sei pronta
apri gli occhi.
Grazie.
[Applausi]